what's going on guys this is Rob and if
you're enjoying the content here on my
channel then make sure you hit the like
button and make sure you hit subscribe
so you can't decide what direction the
content on my channel goes in in the
foreseeable future
okay so as we continue on with Captain
America Steve Rogers again this is just
some amazing storytelling coming from
Nick Spencer but it's been a little
while since we covered this the story so
what I want to do is provide a little
bit of a refresher for those people who
are joining us for the first time or
those people who have kind of forgotten
that's kind of a price you pay when you
start going over stories that come out
monthly is I'm about you guys but you
know if I have to wait six months to
finish your story I'll forget what
happened in the first issue well the
reasons why I kind of like what DC
rebirth is doing by releasing stories
bi-weekly but the vacuum ain't here that
with with Steve Rogers the sea Watchers
that we've known the Captain America
that we've known for really for years
and years and years you know for decades
was always just a champion of freedom in
the United States you know he had
undergone the super-soldier project at
the hands of dr. Abraham Erskine around
the time of one more - he was enhanced
from a sickly lanky guy into a masculine
you know a pretty huge guy which was
kind of indicative what was considered
to be a man's man at that point in time
and Kelly books in the 1960s and in the
result was that Steve Rogers went
forward fighting on behalf of the Allied
powers of course we know that eventually
he's to come to a - an explosion of a
drone plane of the hands of Baron Zemo
ultimately he was frozen alongside Bucky
Barnes who was captured by the Russians
that led to Steve Rogers being sought
out and eventually discovered by the
Avengers and of course he became a super
hero you know as we know him for however
long you've been reading Marvel Comics
so because of that what Nick Spencer did
is he turned the entire landscape on his
head and what he did with a vendor
standoff is we basically saw a story
where a cosmic cube really gets
fractions of different cosmic Eve's over
the years were brought together to form
a singular cosmic you and like all
cosmic cubes that have ever existed in
the history of Marvel Comics this cube
became sentient and adopted the name
comic and that's usually what happens
cosmic herbs if allowed to exist long
enough will develop its sentience and
actually become beams become different
you know organisms sometimes will take
on an alien form but this one comic was
basically a young girl now the reason
why the cosmic you became a young girl
is because it was designed to reflect
the fact that this cosmic cube was
essentially newly created and so its
existence reflected the fact that like a
young child it was still learning about
itself they're also learning what it was
capable of now following Avengers
standoff havoc the Cosmic Cube
which is basically thrown onto the
thunderbolts team and all Marvel did
with that was basically this kind of
keeper in stasis kind of keep her as a
holdover and keep her around so that
when Sigrid Empire comes to an end
presumably when it comes to an end
anyway see Rodgers can be returned back
to the way he was before
by way of topic that Cosmic Cube that's
the most likely ending to that story I
can't guarantee is an absolute certainty
because I don't know the future so so
because of them what make Spencer has
been doing over the course of Captain
America Steve Rogers is going through
and basically showing us what the
updated origin what the new origin for
Steve Rogers is after his past was
modified by the Red Skull now because of
the fact that this history was changed
traditionally Steve Rogers you know
having undergone the Super Soldier
process by Abraham Erskine instead what
this does is this shows us he was raised
by Hydra and because he was raised by
Hydra what ended up happening is he was
sent to the United States as a Hydra
agent for the purpose of killing dr.
Abraham Erskine now initially all we
really knew was that he was just a bad
guy operating behind the scenes but we
didn't really know how deep things went
what this story tells us is that he had
fulfilled his mission arriving in the
United States basically you know getting
an audience with Abraham Erskine
demonstrating the fact that Steve Rogers
himself was the best candidate for the
super soldier process because Erskine
was looking for somebody with a good
moral heart somebody who was able to do
the right thing when it was necessary
and of course this was a ruse that Steve
Rogers is putting on but ultimately he
was selected now with the selection
process because of the fact that Abraham
Erskine never kept notes and because of
the fact that all the information of the
super soldier process was in his head
what this did is it created a difficult
situation because then the question
became what happens if Steve Rogers
going to become the super soldier as he
normally did or is he going to fulfill
his mission kill Abraham Erskine before
he becomes a super soldier and if that
happens how does he become the see
Rogers in terms of his agility strength
speed so on and so forth that were the
most familiar with so again this kind of
bounces back and forth a little bit and
what it does is it transitions to the
funeral of Jack flag now keep in mind
one of the first indications here that
Nick Spencer gave us the Captain
America's history had been modified and
he was transformed into a Hydra agent
was that he had basically killed Jack
flag and again this really goes towards
the evil nature of Steve Rogers
something else that I want to
here is the difference between Hydra and
Nazis one of the biggest misconceptions
out there from people who don't read
Marvel Comics is that Hydra and the
Nazis are the same thing that's actually
completely wrong it's wrong in a lot of
different levels
there's the Nazis which is the Nazis as
you know them led by Adolf Hitler so on
and so forth Hydra is a wholly different
organization Hydra looked at the Nazis
and said they're going about it all the
wrong way they're basically trying to
conquer the world through conventional
warfare Hydra as it was formed or really
as it was reinstated by Baron von
Strucker because Hydra existed some you
know one or two thousand years before
the Nazi Party ever came into existence
Hydra as it was reformed by Baron von
Strucker was designed to exist behind
the scenes it was designed to beat his
hidden hand much like the Japanese ninja
organization in the hand itself or
something along those lines Hydra was
designed to resist behind the scenes and
basically subvert governments across the
world to essentially implement their own
method of taking over the globe by
virtue of just schemes and you know
cloak-and-dagger tactics and things like
that so that's the huge difference but
askew just wanted to eradicate anybody
who wasn't you know part of the Aryan
race Hydra was a far more clandestine
and a far larger and more overarching
organization outside of the Nazi so
that's why I say I wanted to kind of
offer that real quick because again it's
usually a misconception that's held by
people who don't really read Marvel
Comics but because of this with the
death of Jack flag remember Captain
America is the director of shield right
now and people don't know that he's a
Hydra agent no one really knows what's
going on all they know is the face that
he puts on which as far as they're
concerned Captain America is a champion
of freedom you know champion of
liberation different things like that
and so with this dispute Oh more or less
coming to an end what this is designed
to do is show us the Captain America I
guess Steve Rogers is going through the
process of moving things in a direction
made more or less moving chess pieces to
solidify his intention to basically form
his regime to form his secret Empire and
so because of this you know of course he
speaks with Peter quill he speaks with a
few people here and there but the idea
of Carol Danvers championing this device
that's going to create a barrier around
the planet earth to make sure that
extraterrestrial threats cannot invade
the planet is still something inexistent
to keep in mind the reason why that idea
was even launched in the first place was
because of the fact that Steve Rogers
engineered an invasion by the Chitauri
army on the planet Eartha so we
literally set things in motion and
that's how captain
Amerika see Rodgers works it only works
as a Hydra agent because it's a
reflection of how Hydra functions what
Red Skull does what Red Skull is doing
right now in my electronics that's a
reflection of the Nazi Party basically
conquest through warfare what Steve
Rogers does is he says let's move pieces
around the board no one's going to know
that I'm the one that doesn't anybody
who gets close to my identity it's going
to be killed but instead of simply
saying instead of going out to the world
and saying as the director of Hydra I
believe we should make a giant barrier
around the planet Earth instead he
engineers an invasion from the Chitauri
army the people began to panic the
government responds and under the
direction of someone else underdog under
the idea of Carol Danvers the
implementation of a you know global
barrier it's put into play and so again
Steve Rogers gets what he wants he gets
this barrier that keeps anybody from
leaving or anybody from from coming to
Planet Earth without express permission
of shield so again it's basically Steve
Rogers putting himself in a position
where he can make himself absolute ruler
of the world that's really where this is
going in and that's why I say there's
differences between Hydra and Nazi just
because of the fact that it's not about
you know eliminating everybody that's
not of a particular group it's about
just taking over the world about ruling
over everybody equally so I guess you
could say that Steve Rogers is like an
equal-opportunity dictator I guess I
don't know but the fact remains but
switching back to his origin story again
this is where Steve Rogers goes to visit
dr. Abraham Erskine this is really the
moment of truth for his character and
the reason why is because when Abraham
Erskine and Steve Rogers are conversing
with one another by this point they
formed a friendship much like a mentor
and a student and so because of this you
know when his guard is down when Abraham
Erskine invites Steve into his house
Steve begins the process of fulfilling
his mission of killing Abraham Erskine
now while this happens he also basically
speaks directly to somebody that we
can't see he's talking to Saudi off
screen or off panel basically saying the
time has come you know time is basically
running short things are moving faster
than I anticipated and because of that
our timetable has been sped up we need
to begin moving things in a quicker
direction the issue that he faces is
that Steve Rogers is just one man and
what he needs is an ally on his side
that can Corral forces to the side of
Steve Rogers while Steve Rogers himself
continues the guise of being a champion
of freedom in you know in the superhero
community and still trying to move
pieces
around so because of this we jump back
to his past again and this is when
Abraham Erskine you know again tries to
tell Steve Rogers look you can't do this
this is not who you are now
this is what we start to see the
conflicting nature of Steve Rogers and
this is one something that I hope you
notice here in the modern day when its
character is talking to people when we
see his doctor half there is no conflict
there is no struggling to understand his
place there is no question of whether or
not what he's doing is right he is
absolutely sure that he's making the
right decision and so the question
becomes what happened between then and
now what event or series of events took
place that move Steve Rogers from where
he is in his origin story to being
unsure of whether or not he should
actually kill dr. Abraham Erskine to
being where he is now where he knows
that what he's doing is absolutely right
and all the decisions that he's made
over the course of his history were
worth it not only that because of the
fact that Steve Rogers in his past is
very weary very unsure about whether or
not he can actually bring himself to
kill Erskine when the shots fired we end
up learning that the killing shot
actually came from Helmut Zemo so again
this is a reaffirmation of the fact that
Zemo and Steve Rogers have long since
been friends for quite some time now for
swallowing this Zima basically grabs
some device that was created by one of
one of Hydra scientist slaps it on the
head of Abraham Erskine absorbs his
knowledge and calls it a day now the
funny thing about this is that if you're
not a reader of Marvel comics are really
not a reader of comics as a whole this
will basically come off as a throwaway
device and that's exactly what it is I
mean it's basically something that's
just done for the sake of necessity but
what it's also designed to do it's hit
home to the idea this is a very
primitive level of technology in the
sense that it's not like it is now
telepaths were not widely known to exist
around the era and before the era of
world war ii remember it was because of
the formation of the avengers that the
USSR began the process of rounding up
superheroes and Colossus came into play
it wasn't until the 1960s that Charles
Xavier
formed the x-men and so what D is a set
of events taking place some 15 or 20
years prior superheroes were not as
widely prominent and not as well-known
as they came to be later on down the
line and so again there basically was
kind of using whatever is available to
them in order to gain the memories of
Abraham Earth's game but what we also
find out is that Arnim Zola has been
rolled over into Hydra itself it's still
loyal to Hydra and because of its
expertise in the realm of science
intends to basically consolidate all the
information of Abraham
Erskine and then basically implement the
super-soldier program under Hydra itself
and so because of this one is up
happening is homazooma basically says
look Rogers you're supposed to be the
super soldier here you supposed to be
the the main star of this project the
United States the Allied powers believe
that they're that you're on their side
they have to maintain this belief and so
you have to be the one who stumbled in
and discovered the body you have to be
the one who's devastated by the death of
dr. Abraham Erskine again
this is how dark this story gets in
terms of what is origin is but what is
up happening is we find out that in the
modern day this person that Steve Rogers
is talking to you is helmet FEMA and
this is how Nick Spencer squares the
circle one of the big questions that
people have had is when the history of
Steve Rogers was altered by this cosmic
cube did it alter the entire history of
the universe or did it just alter the
life of Steve Rogers what makes Spencer
does here is confirmed that it only
altered the life of Steve Rogers no one
else everybody else is history in terms
of the history of Marvel Comics remains
intact the only history that's changed
are the individuals that we've seen in
the origin of Steve Rogers up to this
point where this new origin of C Rogers
up to this point and the role they play
that's absolutely it now the funny thing
about this is Steve Rogers says this is
an absolute certainty I know these
things to be true but the history of
helmand Zemo in terms of him leading the
Thunderbolts and things like that that's
still intact and so what Steve Rogers
basically says here is look your history
is the history that I remember your
history is of the two of us being
friends your history is of you being at
my side almost every step of the way the
issue is that how much Zemo does not
remember any of that
and so what Nick Spencer is saying is
that somewhere between the time that
this new origin was established with
Helmut Zemo and up until now someone did
something that changed Helmut zimos mind
that changed his memories and so again
there's a lot of forces being pulled
here there's a lot of ambiguity a lot of
information that Nick Spencer is just
kind of trickling in and leaving a lot
of questions to be answered and so again
it's not necessarily that I'm just
leaving information out for you guys
it's what Nick Spencer hasn't
necessarily answer that now this is a
good and a bad thing with this story
basically being a one shot to set the
stage for you know the secret Empire
rising the prelude to of the actual
secret Empire event itself for those of
us who are wildly interested in Captain
America Steve Rogers a key
just coming back for those who were just
now getting into it for those who were
seeking answers or those who are
continuity sticklers it raises problems
and it could turn them off to the story
so again it's just the the gamble that
you take when you're writing a comic
book and it's the risk that Nick Spencer
is willing to go on here but for me as a
reader of Captain America Steve Rogers I
love it because it keeps me asking the
question why doesn't Helmut Zemo
remember the same history that Steve
Rogers remembers why did things change
what happened what did somebody do here
but what Steve Rogers ends up saying is
that whether or not how much Xena
remembers his own past his very actions
can basically guaranteed the fact that
the history that Steve Rogers are
spouting is accurate and the reason why
is because we know that over the course
of his life
Elmo's email formed the Thunderbolts a
team that was basically villains
masquerading as heroes and then
eventually becoming heroes themselves of
course basically being a Civil War
implementation from 2006 when the first
Civil War story was written over the
course of its publication history coma
Zima was always part of the of the
Thunderbolts eventually brand branched
off reformed Hydra or joined Hydra
rather took over the organization as
though it was basically Steve Rogers
saying you've always been a part of
Hydra it's just somebody made you forget
but just by virtue of your subconscious
because your subconscious knows it to be
true you ended up coming back home
anyway
you just don't know why and so because
of this Steve Rogers says look in order
for you to trust me
I have to be able to show that I trust
you and so wear helmets vemma had
basically been held as a prisoner you
know to a degree Steve Rogers
effectively lets all the guard down and
says okay you're a free man
if you do not believe me walk away but
if you believe me join my side and
that's exactly what helmet Zemo does he
joins the side of Steve Rogers and the
two of them go forward with the
intention of basically bringing down the
red skull now because of the fact that
the Thunderbolts team as it had been
reformed by Bucky Barnes and all-new
all-different marvel had essentially
gone underground with Bucky Barnes being
so good at staying hidden something that
was verified during the events of civil
war which is why he was not part of the
first Civil War event despite the fact
that he had returned the thunderbolts
are basically missing in action no one
knows where they are and so because of
this with the new version of plays are
having cosmic awareness meaning that as
long as something is tied in to the
Marvel cosmology quasar can sense where
they are quasar actually senses the
location of Kotik and this is when
quasar basically says
we have to contact Steve Rogers we have
to let him know where cottage is so
again it's Nick Spencer grabbing a lot
of these different themes and pulling
them together basically saying this is
all leading to this revelation that
people are going to start learning what
Steve Rogers is the fact that he's
actually a Hydra agent and the final
little bit of information that he gives
us is the first person to learn the
identity of Steve Rogers who comes in
the form of taskmaster now taskmaster
historically speaking has always been a
B or C list level character he's got a
fan base and he's got a rabid fan base
but taskmaster is probably someone you
would never see in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and I wouldn't be surprised if
right now you're scratching your head
and you have no idea who taskmaster is
taskmaster is basically a guy who
operates behind the scenes 90% of the
time but he is the foremost fighter when
it comes to Marvel Comics his ability in
terms of fighting his prowess allows him
to actually mimic the fighting styles of
other people assuming for whatever
reason he didn't know it but taskmaster
knows almost every single fighting style
in existence he's trained people like
crossbones on how to fight he's trained
a multitude of individuals on how to be
extremely good combatants in
hand-to-hand combat but the fact that
hatch master is basically analyzing the
original footage when Steve Rogers
killed Jack flag which we saw in the
first story arc of Captain America Steve
Rogers which you'll find down in the
description taskmaster basically
overhears the statement that Steve
Rogers makes when he says hail Hydra and
so this is basically taskmaster coming
to the realization that Captain America
is a Hydra agent and so of course the
question becomes now what did you do
with this information is he intend to
blackmail Steve Rogers and if so what
can you hope to achieve out of it
there's you just throw the information
out into the you know for the world to
see that's the question that's being
answered and again this is all leading
up to secret Empire it's all leading up
to the various superheroes across the
Marvel Universe all becoming aware of
the fact that Captain America Steve
Rogers the champion of superheroes
across the Marvel Universe is actually a
Hydra agent but with that being said
guys we're going to go ahead and bring
this video to an end it's just a quick
little one-shot hopefully I didn't throw
too much information at you guys I tried
to you know phrase it in a way that made
sense to try to keep you guys abreast of
everything that's going on if you guys
have any questions though feel free to
post them down in the comment section
but if you are new here to come as
explained be sure to hit the sub button
did it come part of the rob &
yeah leave a like if you enjoy this
video and I will catch you all at it
please
[Music]